R
LAURA INGRAHAM AND THIS IS A
SPECIAL EDITION TONIGHT OF THE
"THE INGRAHAM ANGLE."
ACCORDING TO THE TRACKER, TRUST
IN CONGRESS IS ONLY 33%.
THE SUPREME COURT OF 46%, DOWN
FROM 61% A YEAR AGO, NEWS MEDIA
IS A 38%, AND THE MOST
POLARIZING INSTITUTION IN THE
UNITED STATES.
FRANKLY, IT'S NOT REALLY
SURPRISING.
LAST YEAR THE MEDIA HIT AN HAD N
ALL-TIME LOW AND THEY JUST CAN'T
REBOUND.
ESPECIALLY WHEN IT COMES TO THE
SUPREME COURT "NEW YORK TIMES"
WRITES ABOUT THE BIG POLITICAL
RULING IN THE SENATE REPUBLICANS
TOOK THE POLITICALLY RISKY STEP
OF BANNING ABORTION.
THE THE COURTS TOOK CARE OF THAT
FOR THEM.
YOU WOULD THINK THAT SOMEBODY
WRITING FOR 30 YEARS COULD'VE
GOTTEN THIS RIGHT, BUT WHAT THEY
ACTUALLY DID, YESTERDAY AFTER
THE COURT REJECTED THE CASE,
SOME WORKERS CHALLENGED VACCINE
MANDATES, THE MEDIA WENT AFTER
WHO ELSE BUT CLARENCE THOMAS.
>> INSTEAD OF JUST FACT
CHECKING, SUPREME COURT JUSTICE
CLARENCE THOMAS THAT ALSO WROTE
THAT THIS IS PART OF IT.
>> LET ME BE CLEAR THAT THERE
WERE NO ABORTED FETUS CELLS USED
IN VACCINES.
AND I THINK THAT THIS CARRIES
WEIGHT AND THAT IS THE POINT.
>> LET'S BE CLEAR, THAT'S NOT
WHAT HE SAID IT ALL.
HE SAYS JUSTICE THOMAS INCLUDED
A DESCRIPTION OF THE HEALTH CARE
WORKERS THAT SOME COVID-19
VACCINES WERE DEVELOPED USING
ABORTED FETAL CELLS.
POINTING OUT THIS NUGGET AS
WELL.
SOME VACCINES HAVE USED FETAL
CELL LINES DURING THE EARLY
STAGES OF DEVELOPMENT.
GOT IT?
LET'S MOVE ON.
THERE'S ALSO THE ETA THAT SENT
THE MEDIA AND THE LEFT INTO A
TAILSPIN.
>> RE-WARMING THE CLIMATE,
CAUSING CLIMATE CHANGE.
THE SUPREME COURT HAD CURBED ONE
OF THE MOST EFFECTIVE TOOLS TO
DRASTICALLY CURBING THESE
OMISSIONS.
>> I GUESS IT IS ALL SOMETHING
WE NEED TO CLEAR UP FOR YOU.
CONGRESS DID NOT GIVE THEM THE
POWER IN THE FIRST PLACE TO DO
SO.
THEY MERELY AFFIRM THE FAC